[Music]
hi everybody welcome to Jeff the killer
the game thing I don't actually know
what it's called because I was just sent
it down the link but holy hell I've
never seen a picture up close so okay
alright so this is another Jeff the
killer game but people have been saying
that this is the best one so I'm not
sure it's made on the FPS creator engine
so let's just dive right in get away
from that picture not a good way to
start a game or maybe a great way to
start a horror game I'm not exactly sure
but we'll find out soon enough I have
two thousand health you can't see it
what that
hey whoa buddy's there you need to back
off just a little bit because I'm barely
out of the first room press enter enter
oh shut up
not a bathroom I've got a bathroom
design is this I got a key why did I get
a key seriously what is going on here
I don't
I didn't have any breath left in me
I had no breath like nothing don't do
that what the hell was that oh dang us
stop it
James's balls I'm just barely getting
into this just something else here
another jump scare at this doorway stop
it Jesus balls don't do that I got a gun
yeah Oh bring it on Jeff I have own gun
and I know how to use it this better not
be another space to fire deal like
slender's forced spider
why was there a spider at her I don't
have that many bull oh this cables
topic two stop it I don't know if
shooting Jeff actually does anything he
seemed to go away pretty quickly Jesus
that oh come on
who needs a key where the hell am I
gonna find a key out sits in these two
areas there's no other doors here not a
key on the ground or something something
easy to overlook maybe no man got pin
pricks all over my hands and arms now
not goose bumps you know literally like
feels like there's thing jabbing into my
arms I don't like this
how am I gonna find another key there's
nowhere else to go here wait a minute
wait yeah there's nothing else here what
am I gonna find a key I'm not gonna go
back well there's got to be a key
somewhere around here just so long as it
can stop jumping out of me I should be
fine ah damn maybe I just got a hit
enter wherever I go because I'm
obviously not gonna be able to find a
key something on the bike maybe key bike
bike key I got no key
and we could shoot it open but I'm not
gonna waste my bullets I only got two
left
okay now that we've actually calmed down
and not had constant jump scare zone I
can actually take in the environment and
maybe do some actual game commentary
here maybe Jeff was that something under
the stairs there can't tell I'm gonna
backtrack a bit is there anything over
here no it's a brick wall there
okay I have the key for this one i
unlock that one and all that's left is
the bathroom and there's nothing else
besides the bathroom I I don't know
where else to find a key all right it's
got to be in this front area ergo I
shouldn't deviate too far maybe I just
got a BAM enter as I walk around there's
got to be another key here I mean this
has got to be I can't just oh did I pick
up a key I didn't even see a key
whatever I got it okay I heard a Clank
spamming or wherever I go that's the
winning strategy here Open Sesame
no another jump-scare light turned on
back the [ __ ] up Jeff you break the [ __ ]
up break the [ __ ] up [ __ ] the [ __ ] up
that's from scpi remember that one it's
from scp-871 another ki just hit enter
randomly I did not mean to find that key
whatever whatever I'm winning my skills
at gaming are so beyond the most amazing
MLG gamer
[Applause]
I'm out of bullets I'm officially out of
bullets now that was a waste of ammo I
shouldn't have done that I'm so bummed
oh what's this
can I actually crouch I can I didn't
know seems like this FPS creator angry
I'm angry I'm skrang gree I'm I'm
angered hi Oh
and that's it I did it I can't say that
that game was good I literally can
because when the games just jump scares
it's not a good horror game it's just
surprising because after a while I mean
first yeah you gotta let the atmosphere
do something for you can't just like
immediately
boom boom boom I mean some of you
probably told me that it was the best
Jeff the killer game because you thought
I'd react the most and I did by at the
same time it's not the best Jeff the
killer game because it's not it's not
what I would call a good horror game
because a good horror game needs to let
you build up tension not just throw loud
noises at you and it was the same loud
noise and just a box texture of that
face and I mean that face is creepy and
it's surprising any time you you jump a
human being they're gonna jump because
that's how human beings react to sudden
changes in their environment that's just
the way it is but that's not scary it's
surprising it's not scary well I mean I
was scared but it's not as scary as it
could be if you actually had some horror
going on so I'm gonna get out of this
quick because I don't want that looking
at me so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos it I've done it and as always I
will see you
in the next video bye-bye
[Applause]
[Music]